quatre invités en plateau à présent pour
le prochain quart d'heure de cette
édition du 7 8 véronique guerre non
bonsoir vous êtes ce présidente de la
mission locale plaisir face à vous
gabriel de nomazy bonsoir président donc
du comité yvelines de l'association
valentin haüy également en plateau erika
bonne gastro bonsoir vous êtes mal
voyantes et puis soit il at any bonsoir
à vous vous êtes inscrits à cette
mission locale donc de plaisir et vous a
réuni sur ce plateau ce soir pour une
opération qui relie vos deux structures
valentin avis et puis de l'autre côté
cette mission locale de plaisir avec une
opération qui s'appelle pas tant
d'émotions principe est simple une
personne malvoyante aidé d'une personne
qui est inscrite à la mission locale sur
un tandem comment est né ce projet tout
d'abord alors pour rappeler pour rappel
la mission locale intervient là pour
objectif principal d'intervenir sur les
difficultés que rencontrent les jeunes
dans leurs démarches de recherche
d'emploi
et puis de les coacher sur des attitudes
socialisation et de citoyenneté
et c'est dans ce cadre-là de
socialisation et de citoyenneté que
cette action que ce projet a vu le jour
gabriel de nomazy vous étiez demandeur
pour l'association valentin haüy comment
vous êtes mis en relation pas du tout
vous a sélectionné les accessits et je
pense que
l'adil de plaisir connaissez un peu
l'association pour ce qu'on fait pour
les déficients visuels en général et on
nous a proposé ça sachant que on a une
association qui dans les yvelines
pratiques ont beaucoup le sport et en
particulier le tandem justement
l'objectif derrière tout ça c'est mon
petit tour non non alors l'objectif je
pense que c'était la mission locale de
le dire mais en tout cas pour nous ce
qui nous a permis c'est de faire
rencontrer des déficients visuels à des
jeunes et c'est pas tous les jours ça
leur arrive et puis deuxièmement et ce
qui était encore plus important d'avoir
un rôle je dirais de formateurs il avait
à l'inversé ce qu'ils font d'habitude où
ils sont plutôt formées à différentes
activités le style braille du style
informatique
là c'était plutôt à eux qui étaient là
pour encadrer des jeunes et c'était je
pense extrêmement enrichissant pour eux
mais je pense qu ils le diront encore
mieux que moi les écoutais justement
dans un instant vous allez me dire
comment vous avez vécu cette expérience
on va partir sur le terrain voir
également comment ça se passe mais tout
d'abord véronique dites moi un petit peu
ce que vous souhaitiez apporter
justement aux jeunes qui sont inscrits à
cette mission locale à travers cette
opération alors à travers cette
opération de cohésion c'était plus
qu'une action d'insertion sociale mais
une formidable aventure où le jeune
volontaire de la mission locale pouvait
partager un instant va plus qu'un
instant puisque c'est cette action ce
débat se dérouler sur sept jours une
fois tous les quinze jours avec en
tandem avec un déficient visuel donc de
l'association
valente et invite donc double objectif
pour cette action pour le jeune et c'est
d'être responsable d'une personne
malvoyante personnes handicapées il
faudra la prendre en charge dès que dès
qu'il se retrouve au pied du tandem
jusqu'à là jusqu'au lieu de visite
puisque le lieu c'est de visiter le
patrimoine culturel historique et
touristique du tap du département des
yvelines
donc pour le jeune s'était en effet de
pouvoir acquérir une reconnaissance
reconnaissance au travers de ses efforts
au travers de son action une
responsabilisation pour prennent en
charge le handicap et en transmettant
des des explications par oral de tous
qui voit de tout ce qu'il ressent bien
la prendre
comment cela fonctionne justement va
partir sur terre on va voir quelques
images et puis on va reprendre la
discussion en plateau dans un instant
reportage catherine zola tôt alice
gastines et patrick jacques de dixmude
sur ce dispositif tant d'émotions qui
est organisé tous les quinze jours vous
ne l'avez dit c'est de lundi par mois
ils se tiennent par la main comme de
bons élèves
ils se sont d'abord deux adultes qui
roulent en tandem à jeunes inscrits à la
mission locale et une personne
malvoyante la première fois foot et on
en voit
c'est un petit peu là on a deux yeux
mika je connais juste habilite un peu le
vélo de temps en temps à l'arrière c'est
sûrement mes petites colères avec cette
initiative de la mission locale de
plaisir deux idées fortes prendre
confiance en soi et chasser les a priori
les jeunes ils ont souvent pleins d'à
priori ils n'osent pas aller tout
simplement par les personnes qui sont
différentes et là c'était vraiment
l'occasion de lever des freins aller
vers l'autre osé poser des questions une
fois toutes les questions posées c'est
parti pour un moment autant sportif que
culturel
ça fait pas une balade ça fait quand
même sens de la découverte ça fait de la
culture
et ça aussi la mission locale son coeur
de métier c'est bas de faire accéder à
la culture
les jeunes accèdent à la culture
alors je passe bien très bien ça va
régner démarrage c'est un peu du retard
ça permet de partager entre les jeunes
qui sont souvent mal vu et puis bah des
personnes malvoyantes plus âgés ça
permet de découvrir de nouvelles choses
bon c'est bon pour nous ça a été la
difficulté de leur faire confiance parce
que déjà en tant que non voyant il faut
toujours faire confiance en son pilote
ce n'est pas évident d'autant quand ce
sont des jeunes qui n'ont jamais fait de
tandem
donc ça a été aussi un petit peu
d'émotion pour nous derrag et c'était la
deuxième séance d'une opération qui
porte un joli nom a tant d'émotions à
raison de deux lundis par mois 5 autres
échanges sont programmés et on en parle
donc en plateau avec nos invités on va
demander justement à deux des
participants de témoigner et erika
notamment donc vous également vous avez
participé en tant que déficientes
visuelles
on a entendu une autre personne qui
participait dans le reportage nous dire
que la plus grande difficulté c'était de
faire confiance à l'autre est-ce que
vous aussi vous avez eu cette crainte de
faire confiance de monter sur un tandem
avec quelqu'un qui en avait peut-être
jamais fait oui certainement puisque
en fait dans le temps mais comme nous on
voit pas on est obligé de faire
entièrement confiance au pilote et la
difficulté c'est que ces jeunes
n'avaient jamais fait tandem et
il a fallu que que de piloter on
deviennent en quelque sorte pilotes
puisque l'arrière on leur donnait des
indications sur les changements de
vitesse changement de plateau tout ça
parce que ne savaient pas faire alors on
est sur l'aspect technique mais alors
après sur justement de piloter ce vélo
mais après sur les changes aussi humain
comment s'est passé votre expérience par
exemple échanges humains ça a été très
enrichissant parce que c est certain
nous ont dit qu'il n'avait jamais
rencontré de déficients visuels et
c'était une expérience très riche pour
eux et pour nous aussi de
de communiquer avec ces jeunes
qui parce qu'en fait nous on est quand
même les adultes dans l'histoire et on
leur apporte aussi noté expérience un
peu là comment vous l'avez vécu ou alors
de votre côté en tant que jeune ayant
justement accompagner ces personnes
déficientes visuelles
g je n'avais jamais vraiment rencontré
deux personnes déficientes visuelles et
le fait de les avoir déjà de parler avec
eux ça m'a légèrement en lisant
confiance et comment dire j'ai sur le
vélo je savais faire et je sais faire du
vélo comme tout le monde ça fait des
années que j'en avais pas fait et les
vitesses justement j'avais quelques
soucis et les qui est l'un de ses amis
mama remise en confiance parce qu'il est
très ouvert il parle ici mettre en
confiance
il est il parle il a apaisé
il dégage une confiance en lui énorme
qui se rendaient qui sait transmettre et
pour moi qui n'ai jamais fait de temps
d'aimer qui n'a jamais rien qui n'ait
jamais rencontré de déficients visuels
ça m'a fait une expérience s'agit
cependant découvert et ses expériences à
cette mise en confiance en vous avez
insisté sur cet aspect là c'est
important véritablement au delà du
tandem ça va vous servir a également
peut-être ensuite parce que j'imagine
que c'est aussi là tout de même
l'objectif pour le monde du travail pour
la société en général
vous avez retrouvé confiance en vous par
exemple ou en grande partie oui et comme
confiance
mon entourage et sa chance vraiment mes
idées ma vision sur le monde sur
l'avenir sur forcément satisfait
d'entendre un tel témoignage
moi je suis très satisfaite c'est le but
que l'on souhaite atteindre c'est que
les avant de se vendre
au près d'un recruteur le jeune doit
avoir beaucoup confiance en lui et c'est
au travers d'expériences très formatrice
comme celle ci qu'il peut envisager un
déjà deux au travers d'un rendez vous
avec un recruteur d'avoir davantage de
confiance parce qu'il pourra valoriser
son action et je sais que le recruteur
pourra avoir un bon oeil sur cette
action citoyenne est ce que tous les
jeunes étaient volontaires pour y
participer
ah oui il valait mieux parce qu'il a
fallu les convaincre et non tout de
suite c'est effectivement une bonne idée
alors oui tout à fait donc sur les 800
les 800 éligible un jeune rigide à cette
action bon il y a une dizaine voire une
quinzaine qui se sont présentés et on
voit que il y à une émulation entre donc
c'est très satisfaisant et cette
opération a reçu des soutiens de chacun
notamment ça s'est traduit par des
soutiens financiers
lalande la fondation dexia 4000 euros et
puis l'autre du conseil général des
yvelines c'était hier soir la remise
donc d'échec on voit quelques images du
moment où ça s'est déroulé ça c'est
important ça vous permet aussi de
poursuivre pourquoi pas cette opération
sur le long terme puisque l'aca concerts
dont une partie des jeunes de la mission
locale mais vous imaginez peut-être là
pour suivre tout à fait alors là déjà
l'action nous souhaitions la dérouler la
mettre en oeuvre dès le mois d'avril au
dernier et puis par manque de
subventions et bien cette action s'est
faite aujourd'hui donc on ne désespère
pas le gros de la chasse étaient les
tandems donc les six tandem a acheté
c'est quand même un gros budget grâce au
conseil général voit la fondation dexia
et puis aussi la société sepur nous a
aidés à nous à acheter ou faire les
baudriers pour chacun de nous ainsi que
pour la voiture de sécurité
c'était une initiative propre de la
mission locale parce que la municipalité
s'est impliqué dans le dispositif
non c'est une initiative propre de la
mission locale plaisir bengali voilà
avec le soutien bien sûr de tous mes
collègues de tous les collègues élus
donc de la ville de plaisir et bien sûr
de ceux qui appartiennent aux communes
adhérentes à la mission locale
alors qui a eu cette idée on veut les
noms alors c'est vraiment bien vu passer
entendait même on vous a dit ça c'est
une belle idée alors je vais vous
raconter quand même quand même le le
berceau de cette idée le directeur de la
mission locale est un étang à dire oui
adore le vélo et puis c'est vrai qu'il a
une particularité il a sensibilisation
quant au handicap
et puis
moi je souhaitais aussi une action forte
jaune original sportive peut-être aussi
donc en débriefant en échangeant mavala
le directeur va proposer cette action
qui originale qui est formidable et qui
transmettent qui est là qui fait
partager aux déficients visuels et aux
jeunes une expérience dont je veux
j'espère qu'ils en tireront beaucoup de
conséquences beaucoup de d'aspects
positifs
en tout cas qu'il a l'air d'être le bal
à tout prix qu'à ça à faire danser tout
le monde et nous on est content il
reproduira l'action l'année prochaine
c'est un partenariat durable qui s'est
engagé pour conclure avec l'association
valentin le nom j'espère beaucoup hein
mais il ya un aspect dont on n'a pas
parlé qui paraît aussi très intéressant
dans cette initiative c'est l'aspect
culturel
vous savez il faisait du tandem mais
pour aller visiter quelque chose et je
j'ai écouté ce témoignage lorsqu'ils ont
visité par exemple thouary les
déficients visuels qui par définition ne
voyait pas d'élever des pièces qu'ils
visitent et ont demandé aux jeunes et
décrivez-nous décret nous le salon des
crimes nous ce que vous voyez et je
pense que ça aussi c'était extrêmement
profitable à l'ensemble des participants
une opération qui profita à deux
structures cette opération tant
d'émotions pour avoir plus d'information
contactez aussi la mission locale
un site internet m elle plaisir points
comme et un numéro de téléphone 01 30 79
53 53 01 30 79 53 53 6 est affiché sur
votre écran merci à tous les quatre donc
est revenu sur ce plateau nous parler de
cette opération du côté de plaisir elle
nous allons à présent nous diriger vers
la verrière où un conseil municipal des
jeunes va bientôt voir le jour juste
après un détour par puis on court on
vient d'y célébrer la journée des droits
de l'enfant autour d'une manifestation
réunissant les écoles de la ville sur le
thème des médias anthony rech et le dit
- à l'heure d'internet et de
l'information en continu la toile peut
vite représenter un danger pour des
enfants de neuf ou dix ans
les médias étaient donc le thème de la
journée des droits de l'enfant vendredi
dernier à guyancourt et je ne lui en
courtois ont pour l'instant un accès
limité aux technologies
je mens forme en feu avec mes parents me
j'ai faut vraiment qu'il soit là parce
que sinon
je peux regarder n'importe quoi et où ça
peut être dangereux
quelquefois je suis un ordinateur pour
jouer à des jeux mais c'est si juteux un
quart d'heure maximum pendant cette
journée anniversaire de la signature de
la convention internationale des droits
de l'enfant en 1989
l'objectif est d'essayer de faire
comprendre aux jeunes élèves la
multitude d'informations qui circulent
sur internet et surtout leur crédibilité
par exemple savoir qu'une photo peut
être retouchée avant sa publication
ils se sont glissés dans la peau de
journalistes en créant notamment leur
propre une de journal et en manipulant
du matériel audiovisuel des ateliers qui
vont se prolonger en classe je vais
d'intégrer complètement dans mon
programme travailler sur les journaux
puisqu'on on travaille sur un journal
d'école à l'école on est en plein dedans
voilà et puis et bien sûr en éducation à
la citoyenneté on va reparler tous à la
semaine prochaine près de 500 élèves
d'union courtois ont participé à cette
journée organisée chaque année